now cut man's job is a 12-volt I tend to
a fighters wounds and physical
deterioration throughout a fight in
essence I may be able to save this title
or give them a chance of still I'm
harvelle Jenkins I'm a cop man you
remember tanga Thompson Lord of bullet
train yeah tanga Tom you got knocked out
in three seconds I got a postcard
anything oh yeah I don't know if you're
bright behind every great cut man
there's a great corner man one handball
[ __ ] up you gotta train hard harder than
the other man if you want to win that's
what I install them I fight so I've been
involved in boxing and box and related
matters for the better part of 33 years
it's in my blood that a knee down yeah
Eddie pushes hard
yeah we've been saying to the number of
times about a box of commission I'm a
motivator
I've always enjoyed helping people yeah
I could have been a doctor but my
methods are unorthodox well I mean is it
adversity you know if you can't handle
adversity you don't belong in this game
this ain't ballet I have every possible
solution every possible problem is
watching a pitch a spot where'd you get
that dog there
and got a pretty good man you did it
bounce back in the staff another prawns
on my ears miss Ram
I don't know when boxing we're gonna
recognize some of these techniques I
legitimately like that definite to bag
my groceries down at the sanitary don't
make the dummy in exam